place à la politique à un mois des
élections régionales premier des quatre
débats organisés par notre rédaction
arlette chabot et alain duhamel
reçoivent tout de suite en direct
françois hollande face à nicolas sarkozy
merci alors depuis hier il y à un
nouveau sujet de débat entre vous la
limitation du cumul des mandats lancés
par youn est juste pas beaucoup on avait
parlé lyonnais j'ose pas le fin il a
raison nicolas sarkozy moi je ne savais
pas que c'était la priorité des
priorités que il y avait une urgence à
faire cela chacun bien compris qu'il
fallait tirer un rideau de fumée que le
gouvernement avait des problèmes avec
les chômeurs allaient vite vite trouver
un sujet alors juste un bon peut-être
avec chabon pour préciser qu' on n'a pas
attendu dieu n'existe pas pour découvrir
le problème du cumul des mandats puisque
je vous rappelle que lé nombre des
mandats est limitée aujourd'hui à 2
alors faut-il aller plus loin on peut en
discuter mais je considère que la
proposition qui est faite aujourd'hui
par le gouvernement est une proposition
démagogique inutile pour deux raisons
très simples
la première c'est qu'elle va couper les
parlementaires demandent à et de
responsabilités locales et la seconde
c'est qu'on va donc avoir dans un pays
qui n'a que trop tendance à penser qu'on
résout les problèmes en faisant des lois
des parlementaires qui du 1er janvier au
31 décembre n'auront comme seul sujet
que de bâtir des cathédrales juridique
alors françois hollande c'est une
provision de bon sens il faut des
français faut que des élus soit proche
des français faut qu'ils le soient
disponibles faut que le parlement vive
on sait très bien qu'il y a
effectivement du cumul cumul d'un mandat
d'exécutif local ville très importante
président de conseil général président
du conseil régional avec un mandat
parlementaire ce qui fait que les
parlementaires ne sont pas suffisamment
présents pour voter des lois et
lorsqu'ils sont dans leur
circonscription et bien on le voit pas
ce que ça donne des hémicycles dr alors
je crois que tu fais le retire le plus
grand compte c'est une volonté des
français
c'est une réforme qui je crois s'inscrit
dans le sens de toutes les démocraties
occidentales
ça va se faire ça a été annoncé
aujourd'hui serait peut être annoncé
hier ou demain
le principal à mon avis et de le faire
alors bien sûr que tu auras des
oppositions je les entends ces bourses
et ceux qui sont concernés qu'ils soient
de gauche quelquefois de droite le plus
souvent de droite mais ça peut arriver
de gauche que plus souvent
non mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est quand même pas un drame d'être
élues d'avoir la confiance non mais
j'essaie d'être un problème d'être
candidat à tout et ne pas faire ce que
pourquoi les électeurs ont voulu que
l'on souhaitait lui alors vous avez
ensuite c'est si ça peut être un progrès
puissent conserver sa grande île à cadix
c'est peut être un progrès à mon avis
c'est bien et là où que l'on selon
lequel on serait plus proche du terrain
détacher de la vie locale n'a pas de
sens puisqu'on pourra garder un mandat
local conseiller municipal conseil
général conseiller région pourrait même
être vice-président maire-adjoint mais
on ne pourra plus être maire président
du conseil général président de conseil
général et député ou sénateur
et je crois que c'est un bien alors par
ailleurs sur l'argument du proche du
terrain je me souviens d'une
personnalité qui était connu pour les
cumuls
il avait été président du rpr était
premier ministre et était maire d'une
grande ville
je n'ai pas eu le sentiment qu'il était
très proche du terrain nicolas sarkozy
le gouvernement jospin est en place
depuis presque neuf mois
les français vont voter pour la première
fois de façon significative dans un mois
alors sur quel rivage principaux est ce
que vous avez envie que ceux qui vous
écoutent se détermine moi je crois qui
est évidemment les c'est une question il
faut essayer de répondre le plus
précisément possible nous ne sommes pas
d'accord et dans une démocratie c'est
plutôt d'ailleurs réjouissant qui est
une alternative pour nos concitoyens
moi je dirais très simplement cas depuis
huit ou neuf mois qui vous êtes au
pouvoir à quatre reprises me semble-t-il
vous avez à prendre des décisions
importantes à d'autres reprises mieux
quatre choix me semble important et à
chaque fois de mon point de vue je
respecte bien sûr vos convictions et de
mon point de vue vous n'avez pas fait le
choix du bon sens puisque c'est un choix
idéologique et surtout vous avez
entraîné la france dans une direction
strictement inverse à celle des grandes
démocraties notamment européennes jeu
très rapidement l'immigration tous les
pays modernes et toutes les démocraties
ont tendance aujourd'hui à resserrer
leur législation pour éviter les flux
migratoires
nous essaierons et nous ouvrons les
possibilités
c'est le fameux code de nationaux en
supprime la déclaration de volonté
deuxième élément
tous les pays sont confrontés à un
problème de natalité
nous sommes la france avec une politique
familiale depuis 1945 qui nous permet de
tous les pays européens d'avoir le taux
de natalité le moins mauvais on
démantèle totalement la politique
familiale notamment ce que tu tout à
fait inadmissible en posant des graves
difficultés aux femmes qui veulent à la
fois élever leurs enfants et avoir une
vie professionnelle
troisième élément c'est les emplois
aubry de tous les grands pays européens
nous sommes celui qui a le plus
d'emplois publics
le poids des dépenses publiques le plus
lourd et qu'est ce que nous faisons on
envoie contre toute évidence et contre
tout bon sens trois cent cinquante mille
jeunes dans des emplois ne sont
fonctionnaires et enfin dernier point
mais j'imagine qu'on aura l'occasion
d'en parler je ne veux naturellement pas
mobilisé de débats au moment une
compétition internationale formidable se
présente on veut faire croire aux
français cette idée j'espère qu'ils ne
sont pas du camp travail au moins ça ira
mieux qu'on gagnera plus et qu'en plus
il ya des emplois pour l'entente
salanque choix à quatre choix contraire
un concert en finlande l'immigration
d'alors
juste un mot ce qu'on fait depuis huit
mois
monsieur sarkozy a résumé à 4 points j'y
reviendrai ce qu'on fait quand même
depuis huit mois
c'est de remettre le pays sur un sentier
de croissance est bien la croissance est
repartie on a les chiffres qui sont
connus aujourd'hui une croissance près
de 3% france par consommation cette
année parce que sinon c'est grâce à vous
on a 300 ça fait huit mois et coûté en
tout cas elle n'était pas là un bon iver
elle est là maintenant mais si vous avez
10 ou pas vous mais en tout cas le prix
de la république qui est votre
responsable principal si on a dissous
l'assemblée c'est parce que on pensait
que ça n'irait pas forcément beaucoup
mieux après sinon leurs efforts faits en
fonction alors ça n'a pas beaucoup
augmenté dans huit mois mais par l
exemple du show en accroissant et goûter
un peu d'exercice
elle repart et si elle repasser parce
que on a soutenu la consommation ce que
vous ne faisiez pas deuxièmement on a
bouclé les exercices budgétaires qu'on
nous annonce est extrêmement difficile à
terminer et notamment par rapport à la
préparation de rendez vous européen et
puis troisièmement on a repris une
mécanique de création d'emplois la
meilleure preuve c'est que le chômage
pour le mois de décembre
en tout cas a fléchi heureusement même
si ce n'est qu'un signe et qu'il faut en
attendre beaucoup d'autres pour en être
certain alors non je reprends les cas
dominera sur l'immigration nous avons
voulu retrouver l'équilibré il y avait
eu
texte apparemment dur en fait
inappliquée inapplicable c'est ce qu'on
avait appelé les lois pasqua qui avait
profondément désorganisé le système
administratif qu'on ne connaissait jeter
dans l'illégalité des personnes qu'on
n'arrive même pas à expulser
il fallait trouver une règle elle a été
trouvée c'est une règle simple
c'est-à-dire durs à l'égard de
l'immigration clandestine et en même
temps d'intégration pour ceux qui sont
sur notre sol de façon sûre et julien
obry l'arrivée de l'ancien parce que
sinon on n'a pas joué les quatre points
mais après vous avez jamais mort 2e
partie non non c'est vrai d'accord
d'accord c'est un débat entre françois
hollande et à la maintenance si vous
entrez le nom mais question immigration
la question vous avez demandé sur la
pression des sans papiers et des verts à
ce que l'ensemble des immigrés en
situation régulière se déclare d'après
les chiffres de jean pierre chevènement
hier aux environs de 120000 irrégulier
qui sont déclarés vous en avez
régularisés enfin ne pas vous le
ministère de l'intérieur va 1000
la question qui se pose ce que vous ne
régularisera pas est ce que vous leur
demanderez de quitter le territoire
national
est ce que vous vérifierez que ça se
fera bien sûr nous nous avons voir une
régularisation sur la base de critères
quels étaient les critères je devais pas
être trop long les critères familiaux
est-ce qu'ils étaient mariés ou en
compagnie d'une personne qui était de
nationalité française
est-ce qu'ils avaient des enfants est-ce
qu'ils avaient un travail est-ce qu'ils
étaient présents sur le territoire
depuis plusieurs années si les critères
sont remplis
ces personnes ont vocation à être
régularisés et d'ailleurs il y avait des
rives de la région bien avant ce
dispositif si les normes parents
deuxième ambition ils ne sont pas s'ils
ne sont pas régularisable eh bien ils
seront reconduits à la frontière par les
mécanismes que l'on connaît sans
brutalité sans violence mais avec le
respect de la loi parce que c'est la
règle dans ce pays l'état de droit donc
pour les normes à 1000 noms vous voyez
venir combien vous on expulserait
interprète selon le nombre de
régulariser vous aurez le nombre de
personnes qui seront reconduits à la
frontière
mais la différence entre ce que l'on
fait et ce que vous avez fait c'est que
vous faisiez des lois pour jaillir
l'incantation
parce que c'étaient des lois apparemment
sévère mais en fait très tolérante à
l'égard de l'immigration clandestine
parce que les sanctions n'étaient pas
forte nous avons renforcé les sanctions
contre
l'immigration d'origine et nous avons
une politique humaine plan que je passe
au deuxième fois parce que sinon je
jouais pas que justin et les bas que non
mais on passe juste mais au nom d'al sur
ce seul sujet nature nous n'avons pas
que cela n'a dû à l'entrée pour être
juste arrivé conservation vous savez
qu'en matière d'immigration
que vous vouliez vous dire que la racj
et le débat ce nom et non pas du tout je
sais j'ai tapé la tonalité qui est la
bouille depuis six mois
absolument pas je voulais c'est terminé
je termine sur l'immigration vous savez
très bien que les mots ont un sens il
faut respecter la dignité des hommes et
des femmes mais tout laxisme se paye
immédiatement par un gigantesque appel
d'air les socialistes avec monsieur
leroy vous nous l'avez fait en 1982 je
regrette de mon point de vue y compris
pour l'intérêt des immigrés en situation
régulière que nous devons respecter que
vous recommenciez les mêmes erreurs qu'à
remet les mêmes causes produiront les
mêmes effets enfin côté sous le laxisme
je crois pas qu'on ait de leçon à
recevoir
vous avez tout le monde là l'esprit sur
l'église saint bernard
il fallait à tout prix rentrer dans
cette église fracassé la porte renvoyé
les gens combien y at il eu d'expulser
très peu parce que ben votre législation
n'était pas applicable
alors s'il vous plaît sur ce point on
s'est plutôt à des textes qu'ils sont
humains qui évite ce type de
manifestation douteux normal et qui en
même temps
khider a été reconduite alors conduire
un taxi sur son poulain failli femme il
ya aussi et vito ce type d'incantation
sur la famille je crois que nous avons
nous augmenter l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire
nous avons permis une amélioration de la
situation de beaucoup d'enfants dans les
cantines
nous avons permis là encore tout
récemment que les aides soient versées
directement au collège et par personne
nous avons augmenté d'une manière
générale les prestations familiales
alors c'est vrai nous avons nous sous
condition de ressources les allocations
familiales parce qu'il ne nous
paraissait pas logique
mais je comprends que vous ayez un avis
différent d'ailleurs ça correspond aussi
à votre électorat
je comprends que vous ne puissiez pas
admettre qu'au delà de 30 mille francs
et même quelquefois davantage lorsqu'on
a plusieurs enfants ils ne soient pas
utile de continuer à verser des
allocations familiales de ce point de
vue nous avons un débat philosophique et
nous pouvons revendiquer chacun notre
part de vérité
troisièmement selon m
pourtant ces délicieux mais il ya aussi
alain duhamel
non mais sérieusement vous affirmez moi
je me contente que je ne pars pas
d'arlette chabot des questions sur cette
affaire de politique familiale je veux
dire deux choses très violent dans un
pays qui a plus de 3 millions de
chômeurs empêché les familles mais quel
degré mais de quelle famille car je
jouais je cale famille si vous acceptez
que je prononce trois phrases vous
permettra les critiques à 8 dans un pays
qui est plus 3 millions de chômeurs
empêché les familles de créer des
emplois qui bénéficions à des gens qui
sont loin d'être privilégiés et bien
c'est une erreur monumentale car les
emplois familiaux c'est un formidable
gisement d'emplois outre le fait que ça
permet à des tas de familles de classe
moyenne de pouvoir avoir les femmes qui
choisissent une carrière professionnelle
et qui en même temps pour s'occuper de
leurs enfants
deuxième élément mais qu'est ce qui vous
est passé par la tête il ya un million
deux cent mille femmes veuves ou femmes
seules qui ont élevé un enfant à qui
vous avez supprimé la demi part vous
pouvez quand même pas dire que c'est un
million deux cent mille personnes
s'étaient des possédants qu'il fallait
absolument traités de la façon dont vous
avez changé de sujet baisser la marge
aux jeux vous reste que les femmes est
aussi question on se fait que vous
répondiez donc pour d'abord pour les
femmes qui travaillent
rien n'est fait pour les dissuader vous
aviez créé un système notamment de
déductions fiscales qui était
profondément choquant seigneur vous
qu'il avait créée c'est mon père n'était
effet c'est faux c'était très très bon
système vous voulez que je réponde
peignant un message que vous vous
prétendez que vous ne le faisiez jamais
donc vous aviez introduit un système qui
permettait une réduction du montant de
l'impôt de 45 mille francs ce qui
aboutit c'est vous encore une viande et
de santé ou le salaire des verts s'est
expliqué ce que vous avez fait et tenir
marre de payer les impôts si je savais
aussi répondre à leurs questions ce
serait quand même du président mais je
vais adhérer précision ce superbe
attendez vous aider je vous ai remettent
et non mais je n'ai pas besoin de vous
qu'on s'était donné ce qui permettait à
des foyers fiscaux de déduire de leurs
impôts
quarante cinq mille francs ce qui
aboutissait à ce paradoxe extraordinaire
c'est que l'employeur de personnel de
maison pouvait se retrouver non
imposables dès lors qu'ils
payer un peu moins de quarante cinq
mille francs d'impôt sur le revenu alors
que l'employée de maison elle ou lui se
retrouver redevable de l'impôt sur
l'audience s'il vous plaît je pense que
nous n'avons pas envie de retrouver des
mécanismes fiscaux aux signes toit
anthracite doit gêner votre disposition
s'ils étaient profondément choqué mais
je la règlement elle a été réduite de
moto je la revendique
elle a permis de créer des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois et pardon de le dire
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi
lorsqu'une entreprise verse un salaire
elle ne paye pas d'impôts sur le salaire
qu'elle verse à ses salariés et
lorsqu'une famille verse un salaire qui
devra payer un impôt
il ya des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui ont tué un salaire et ce
qui a permis de faire d'électrisation
pour la sécurité sociale
lebel panache de karl vernay avec celles
et ceux qui adorent les déclamer liale
ce qui a permis de donner de l'emploi ne
donner du pouvoir d'achat car voyez vous
moi je trouve qu'il est beaucoup plus
intelligent que ceux qui le peuvent
créer les emplois plutôt qu'on ne
voudrait pas besoin d'enrichir les
dirigeants pour que les fonctionnaires
c'est peut-être ça qui nous distingue
c'est que vous vous emmènera j'ai les
plus favorisés pour leur cause mais j'ai
répondu présent puisque vous avez sonné
les désirs mieux en mieux
les emplois jeunes puisque vous avez
évoqué les nounous 13 0 sinon c'est des
emplois jeunes qui vont effectivement
travaillé dans des tâches d'utilité
collective plutôt que de continuer à
subventionner comme vous le faisiez des
emplois qu'ils pouvaient être
solvabiliser comme on dit par le marché
alors oui nous préférons créé 350 mille
emplois jeunes
et moi je suis plutôt fier qu on ait pu
donner à des jeunes qui aujourd'hui
attendent un emploi et bien cette
perspective de s'insérer dans la société
vous pouvez être con je sais pas si à
neuilly vous n'avez pas créé d'emplois
jeunes je suppose puisque vous en veut
contester le principe je suppose que
vous n'avez pas créé on avait créé une
critique dans la ville vous aimeriez
vous cette chaîne mais elle n'appelle
pas le problème je vous ai posé la
question est-ce que vous avez que je
vous répondrai simplement
s'agissant des emplois jeunes c'est une
erreur monumentale est facile une erreur
monumentale pourquoi mais est ce que
vous avez créé art je vais vous le dire
mais je vais faire mon raisonnement
parce qu'on fait croire aux jeunes que
leur avenir est dans l'administration le
problème c'est que nous avons des poids
de dépenses publiques trop lourd trop
d'emplois publics
nous avons 7 % d'emplois publics les
autres plus imagé
les envoie dans ce système là je crois
aux emplois d'utilité sociale monsieur
hollande mais permettez moi de vous dire
ces emplois devraient être réservés à
ceux de nos compatriotes donc de chômage
depuis trois ans n'avait pas créé dans
rage en cinq ans et certainement pas
pour des jeunes à bac + 2 à bac + 3 qui
serait beaucoup mieux que les anglais
en ce qui me concerne enseignants les
lignes du rapport au cdi
j'en ai créé sanogo vellas richard va
participer à ce système aussi d'un
médecin aussi nuisible que celle que
vous aimez vous êtes peu mieux vous êtes
tellement impatients vous êtes un peu
long à la mémoire je vous en voyez ma
plaque est tout simplement parce que moi
je te considère que cette loi est pas
une bonne n'en voulait avec mme merkel
doit appliquer à partir du moment où
c'est la loi de mon pays d'accord donc
chacun n'arrête pas qu il ne m'apparaît
pas de jeunes doivent pas lacombe
viendra faire le trou et rose avoir
votre propre à ce qu'on nous c'était une
première pour appliquer des lois parce
que la loi est la loi puisse y jouer si
je pense soit pas confiée pour moi comme
vous l'avez pas là mais hyper 20 aussi
dans le jeu aussi fatale pour les jeunes
je n'aurais pas créé ce disponibles donc
je nous nous considérons que nous avons
un vrai qu'il n'est pas fonctionnaire on
tond d'avenir des jeunes étant
l'entreprise dont ils ont tiré dans
consacré l'utilité sociale
si un emploi d'utilité sociale pour un
homme ou une femme qui n'a pas travaillé
depuis quatre ans s'est parfaitement
nécessaire parce que personne ne pourra
le trouver une place dans une entreprise
un emploi dans l'administration ne
souffre actionnaires pour un jeune c'est
une rencontre du mondial contre bayonne
au sein de l'esa du pays a laissé cette
illusion pour se propager à neuilly mais
visiblement vous avez les 35 heures ce
qu'on veut c'est qu'il y ait plus
d'emplois
nous avons soutenu la croissance elle
repart nous avons créé les emplois
jeunes et nous en sommes fiers et tant
mieux si monsieur sarkozy en a créé 6 à
neuilly nous voulons aussi qu'il y ait
un système de réduction du temps de
travail qui permettent de créer des
emplois non pas autoritairement il y à
une loi
cette loi va être votée je l'espère l'a
déjà été approuvé par l'assemblée
nationale
et elle va ouvrir pendant deux ans la
négociation sur cette négociation il y
aura des accords et je constate déjà que
beaucoup d'entreprises veulent conclure
des accords pour créer des emplois alors
on nous dit mais vous allez demander à
travailler - offensés mais aujourd'hui
il ya trois millions cinq cent mille à
peu près selon les statistiques
si on qui servent de référence depuis
des années personnes qui sont demandeurs
d'emploi cela on ne demande pas
travailler plus ou travailler moins ils
ne travaillent pas du tout et puis il ya
aussi toute cette population qui
travaille à temps partiel car vous avez
beaucoup encouragé le temps partiel et
ce temps partiel est souvent rémunérés
c'est normal puisque c'est du temps
partiel inférieur au smic
alors oui nous préférons créer un
système qui réduisent le temps de
travail de façon intelligente avec une
organisation différente du travail avec
des aides très importantes de la part de
l'état car nous préférons nous verser
des exonérations de charges sociales aux
employeurs qui créent des emplois plutôt
que sans contrepartie
nous voulons lancer un processus de
négociations qui permettent de créer des
emplois et j'espère bien que la
croissance
les emplois jeunes la réduction du temps
de travail aboutiront à faire que ce
pays ait moins de chômage depuis quinze
ans il y à toujours plus de chômage tout
majorité confondues et bien moi je suis
mandaté aujourd'hui par mes électeurs
par les électeurs de la majorité pour
qu'il y ait moins de chômage de sarkozy
décrue du chômage
pour mieux régner sur les 35 heures
c'est une triple erreur
la preuve c'est que les pays qui étaient
très en avance sur nous sur les 35
heures vient d'y renoncer c'est le cas
de l'allemagne
c'est sans doute un autre débat c'est
une triple erreur 1er junior ceux qui
nous regardent nous écoutent doivent
savoir que le partage du temps de
travail qui sera imposée par les
socialistes s'ils vont le payer par un
partage des salaires je suis persuadé
que l'objectif de nos compatriotes c'est
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat ce qui
nous avait pas de lendemain il ya huit
ans nous revient sur nos premiers
éléments c'est une erreur sociale
vous allez le payer du réduction du
salaire alors que de tous les pays
développés
la première mi temps est celui des
salaires les plus bas c'est ensuite une
erreur économique majeure tous les pays
qui risque qui réussissent dans la lutte
contre le chômage réussissent avec cette
volonté de créer des richesses et non
pas cette frénésie de partager la
pénurie partager le temps de travail n'a
marché nulle part ailleurs dans le monde
pourquoi voudriez vous que ça marche
chez nous et enfin c'est un contre sens
complet sur les valeurs dont se porter
notre société pourquoi parce que le
travail c'est une émancipation
ce n'est pas une aliénation parce que
c'est le travail parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui volent du travail je vous ai
déjà dit régis terminer le travail
c'est ce qui rend sa dignité à l'homme
et c'est par le travail bien sûr le
progrès c'est pour ça qu'on se crée des
emplois laisser à penser qu'en
travaillant 35 heures vous vous dites 35
heures madame voynet
ces deux ministres qui passent au vert à
faire les manifestations et d'abord pour
les 32 heures puis bientôt l'année
prochaine pour les 28 heures
c'est un contresens total et laisser à
penser à nos compatriotes qu en
travaillant moins on pourra gagner plus
et créer des emplois pour leurs enfants
c'est un mensonge je pêche ou non
d'ailleurs j'aurais à dire à ceux qui
nous regardent pourquoi voudriez vous
que nous fassions nous pour la france ce
que vous faites pas pour votre famille
et j'ajoute qu'il est plaisant de voir
martine aubry grande prêtresse des 35
heures faire faire sur elle des
portraits complaisants ou la montre à la
tête de 18 heures de travail quotidien
si c'était si bien la réduction du temps
de travail pourquoi maintenant nous
verrons je serai faire des portraits
extraordinaire montrant combien elle est
acharnée aux travaux alors répondre je
répondrai pas ce type de critiques sur
madame voynet madame aubry je pense que
vraiment ça mérite des ministres un jeu
des ministres travaillent et madame vous
plaît faites le travail voilà plutôt
rassurant pour les français si on est
mandaté les uns les autres pour servir
notre pays c'est pour travailler et ça
doit travailler tant que les autres
élèves devraient aujourd'hui s'il vous
plaît que ceux qui sont complémentaires
se dénoncent au mcs est ce que c'est on
va par là j'irai paraître pour que lié à
la fois la majorité et l'opposition
qu'ils soient dans le même gouvernement
voulait vraiment ridicule cette journée
folle attendez laissez moi parler ce que
je veux vous dire c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas utiliser de tels arguments ce
qui compte dans ce pays ce sont les
personnes qui veulent travailler et qui
ne le peuvent pas et quand ils vous
entendre monsieur sarkozy leur bien mais
il faut travailler plus il faut vraiment
travailler parce que dans notre société
c'est le travail qui qu ils ont envie de
vous dire mais si c'est le travail qui
compte pourquoi vous ne leur donnez pas
pourquoi vous ne vais pas donner quand
on est français
attendez vous tous les autres pays ofaj
entre système pendant veste et les ans
dans les allées c'est les dépenses
alléger les commandants les
responsabilités le chômage a augmenté
vous pouvez pas
car s'il n'avait pas abandonné monsieur
jean tu ne m'avais s'ils avaient
augmenté s'il n'avait pas 194 216e
nature à augmenter monsieur bah ça serai
président de la république monsieur
chirac aurait réussi la dissolution
pascal magic aussi parce que nous sommes
jugés parce que nous sommes jugés sur ce
résultat là pendant quatre ans
la droite a considéré qu'il fallait
attendre la croissance qu'elle allait
revenir que la reprise était au bout du
chemin
à l'inversé des exonérations de
cotisations sociales très importantes de
50 à 70 milliards aux entreprises parce
qu'elle pensait que la baisse du coût du
travail et à des fois tu sais j'ai fait
monsieur et bien nous avions concernés
mois nous avons vu nos jardins se
remettre du chômage
aujourd'hui il y a des solutions
nouvelles alors vous ne partagez pas
c'est bien votre droit mais laisser ce
gouvernement au moins pour suivre dans
sa logique parce que je crois que les
emplois jeunes plus de croissance ça ça
s'appelle la création de richesses et ça
vaut pas et une négociation utile habile
intelligente sur le travail permettront
de créer les emplois que vous n'avez pas
créé alors la sarkozie avant la
conclusion de françois hollande
oui mais écoutez moi je souhaite bien
évidemment pour le pays que ça réussisse
simplement le petit problème c'est qu'en
même temps on nous dit qu'on va faire
l'euro la construction européenne
amsterdam ont fait le contraire de ce
que font tous les autres
le chômage n'est pas une fatalité pour
la raison simple c'est que partout
ailleurs dans le monde le chômage recule
profondément donc une façon donc une
manière et dans un cas un pays on arc
fait reculer le chômage en créant des
emplois de fonctionnaires en imposant la
réduction du du la durée de travail en
matraquant les familles et en augmentant
les impôts donc malheureusement cette
politique sera conduite à l'échec
les français auront l'occasion de le
dire j'espère de tout coeur qu'ils le
feront lors des prochaines élections
régionales que tu sarkozy et les
répondants de l'opposition ne croit pas
à l'utilité de soutenir la consommation
c'est leur droit
il ne croit pas aux emplois jeunes
isolons parfaitement la liberté il pense
que la réduction du temps de travail
n'est pas utile au pays
parfait c'est leur droit mais en même
temps nous nous voulons utiliser des
formules nouvelles parce que les
anciennes celles qui a impliqué monsieur
sarkozy celle que nous avons pu nous
aussi à une autre époque
appliquez n'ont pas marché et pour
autant nous faisons l'europe
nous respectons nos engagements
européens à la date prévue et avec des
meilleurs résultats
financiers en définitive ce qui nous dit
ça c'est que nous nous respectons nos
engagements électoraux et nos
engagements européens
merci à tous les vieux dans une semaine
nous nous retrouverons avec l'elysée
vestnik vous face à jean-louis devrait
dans un instant surtout ne ratez pas
envoyé spécial 10 jours à matignon et
demain matin dans les quatre vérités
je sais bien que marie pierre farkas
recevra ladern trautmann de bonsoir
bonsoir